MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this video, we'll talk
about the nuclear shell model.
We've already seen an
interesting empirical model
to describe nuclear binding
energies-- the liquid drop
model.
But it comes short
in the description
of all aspects of the nucleus.
So let's see what
we can find here.
First of all, you probably
remember shell models
from atomic physics.
And shell models are very
successful in describing
hydrogen, for example.
The question is, can this
also work for the nucleus?
After all, the nucleus
is a many-body system,
compared to hydrogen, where you
have a proton and an electron
circling around.
There's no analytic solutions,
like the Schrodinger equation.
There is no dominant center
for a long-range force,
like the proton has been
the dominant center.
And we have short-range
forces with many pairs
of interacting nucleons.
And I can continue the
list of difficulties.
On the other hand, the
interactions kind of
average out and result
in a potential which
depends only on the
position, but not
on the timing of the nucleus.
And that leads us, then, to what
we call a nuclear mean field.
So on average, our proton and
our neutron inside the nucleus
sees a specific potential.
And we can use that, then,
parameterized as potential
with a harmonic oscillator,
and use that model, then,
in order to describe
our nucleus.
So this works, actually,
surprisingly well.
But before we go there, we'll
look at experimental evidence
for closed nuclear shells.
So again, here is our plot
of the binding energy.
And you see that there
are those areas here
that seem to be some sort
of higher binding energies.
And it turns out those happen
at so-called magic numbers.
Magic numbers are 2,
8, 20, 28, 50, and 126.
So the question now is,
how can we explain this?
Where does this come from?
So again, the experimental
evidence is numerous.
We find that the number of
stable isotopes or isotones
is significantly higher
for nuclei with a proton--
or neutron, or both--
numbers equal to one
of those magic numbers.
The nuclear capture
cross-section,
meaning the likelihood to
capture a proton or a neutron,
are high for nuclei where
exactly one nucleon is
missing from a magic number.
But it's significantly
lower for nuclei
with number of nucleons
equal to the magic number,
meaning that there is this
concept of a closed shell.
We either just add a
nucleon to close it
or you have to pay
a higher price.
The energy of excited states for
nuclei with a proton or neutron
number equal to the magic
number are significantly higher
than for other nuclei.
And these are all
experimental observations.
And the excitation probabilities
of the first excited states are
low for nuclei with a
proton-- or neutron, or both--
numbers equal to
the magic numbers.
Quadruple moments-- we haven't
discussed those at length,
but you can think about them
as deformations of the nuclei.
They almost vanish for nuclei
with proton or neutron numbers
equal to the magic numbers.
So those are more kind of
sphere kind of objects.
Here's a plot which
shows or points
out the double magic numbers--
as in, those are a nucleus
where both the proton
number and the neutron number
are laying on the magic number.
So calcium here
has two of those,
with 20 protons and 20 neutrons,
or 20 protons and 28 neutrons.
And there's alphas.
Those are specifically
interesting object of research.
There was some historic
confusion in this,
and it came from the fact that
while the experimental data
pointed to nuclear magic numbers
of 2, 8, 20, 28, 50, and 126,
if you just think about a
flat bottom potential, just
a flat potential, you
find magic numbers which
are 2, 8, 20, 40, 70, and 112.
And those are typically
not in agreement.
So therefore, it seemed like
that this shell model kind of
worked, but not really.
We found agreement here,
but then disagreement
in the higher part
of the magic numbers.
So something was missing.
And so what was missing
was the spin-orbit part
of the discussion.
We alluded to this
in the nuclear force.
What you have to do is, beyond
three-dimensional harmonic
oscillator, you have to
add the spin-orbit coupling
to the Hamiltonian.
And when you do that,
you change the orbit such
that the magic numbers agree
with the experimental data.
So you see here, the
potentials for proton,
which has also the
Coulomb repulsion added,
and the nuclear
potential, and then you
see that the spin-orbit coupling
slightly changes the potential.
All right.
As a comparison here,
the nuclear and atomic
shell models, just
for an example.
And you see we call them shells
because we see that the energy
gaps between individual
shells are quite large, much
larger than within the shell.
And the same-- this is
for the atomic model.
And for the nucleus,
you see very similar.
So it's not that extended, but
still larger gaps in energy
when you go from one
state to the next.